- I'm not normally embarrassed
by the extent of my subject
at the beginning.
But I can hardly compete with the idea
of explaining all behavior
and social activity
from fundamental axioms of physics.
So I'm gonna focus on
a much smaller problem,
which is trying to
understand the visual system
in the mouse.
And I'll motivate this through
the course of this talk,
but it actually comes from
a deeply held philosophical
belief about research,
which is, if you can
choose the right problem,
and dig into it deeply enough,
then you're likely to learn lessons
that will inspire the solution
to other related problems,
and then in fact,
help you even to be
able to formulate them.
And so for those of you
who don't care about
biological visual systems,
I've changed the intro to the talk
based on several of the
comments that I heard yesterday
and today, which is about
the rise of AI in science,
and in our culture in general.
So Priya, this is my
attempt to get large again.
And the question is
whether these artifacts
are actually doing things
like this other intelligent
machine that we know about,
at least at the level
of our visual systems.
And as I'm sure everyone
in this room knows,
deep networks came out
of a very crude analogy
with a very crude model
from the late 1970s
by David Hubel and Torsten Wiesel
modeling the early
visual system in the cat.
And this model has now been extended
into the foundation of much
of the deep learning aspect
of modern AI.
And there is in fact a something
of a Manhattan project going on
that wants to build an identity
between these deep networks
and the structure at
least of visual systems.
And frankly, I was struck a
lot by your comment yesterday
about whether we're writing papers
that are only to be read by machine.
And that takes this actually
to a much higher level.
Is the nature of this intelligence
anything like what we
would call intelligence?
Like, I don't know the
answer to the big question,
but I'm gonna try to address that,
at least at the level
of the visual system.
And, so how might you go about this?
And my goal here is to set the stage
and introduce our
algorithmic approach to this.
Well, there's some unknown
neural network in say,
a visual system,
and we excite it with some
stimulus of one sort or another.
And we record the activity,
we measure the activity,
and I believe the
philosophers in this room
would call that an experiment.
And the question is, once
you do an experiment,
what do you do with all those data?
In our case, we're going
to deal with the mouse
because it is the system of choice
for much of modern biology.
And so these mice are
pretty good at wandering
through the world and surviving.
And so there's sort of
three questions, which are,
what are the stimuli that we should use
to excite the visual system of the mouse
in a non-trivial fashion?
And how do we build some notion
of what the circuits might be
that are underlying that activity?
And we would like to be able to do this
by analyzing the data that we
acquire through experiments.
Now, there's of something of
a history to this subject,
which is very anti-mouse, which,
if you take the mouse and
put it in the laboratory,
as we would all go to the ophthalmologist
and measure the acuity of these animals,
it turns out that mice
are effectively blind.
That is to say,
if I asked how well you
could see something small,
like say your thumbnail,
held at arm's length,
say your thumbnail at arm's length
is about one degree of visual angle.
And the acuity of a mouse
with respect to that
is only less than 10%
as good as being able
to see something like your thumbnail.
So if a primate were viewing a scene
like the one that you
see here on the right,
then it would see a pattern
like this blurry mess over there.
So this says that maybe the
mouse is not the right creature
to be using for visual experiments,
despite the fact that
there's so much known about it
genetically and biologically
and so many imaging capabilities.
But if you go down a level,
you see that the neural
machinery in the mouse
is very analogous to the
neural machinery in cats
as Hubel and Wiesel used
them, or in the primate.
Maybe there's something
else that's going on here
that requires a little
bit of understanding.
And that is,
is the stimulus that your
ophthalmologist would use
to design your glasses,
the right kind of stimulus to be using
in evaluating the visual
system of the mouse?
So we thought about that,
and from a mathematician's
perspective, what do mice do?
Well, they run around in fields,
looking for crickets
and other things to eat.
So if you picture yourself as a mouse
running through a field,
there's lots of grass
and shrubbery and whatnot
at the scale that matters to you.
And so as you're running
through the field,
you see this kind of
waterfall of shrubbery
and grass flowing by.
And this led us, as mathematicians,
to build a collection of flow patterns
that are an abstraction of
that class of visual stimuli.
And my colleague, Michael Stryker,
has used these flow patterns
to assess the visual system of the mouse.
And there's a key data science point here,
which is the flows are
much more naturalistic
than the artificial stimuli
that you see on the left
side of your screen.
But they're also much
more amenable to analysis
than natural images,
which are essentially an
uncontrolled class of stimuli
that you see on the right.
So to get the experiments to work,
you need to be somewhat
cognizant of the stimuli.
Now, how are these experiments done?
We're the mathematicians.
This is all done by my colleague,
Michael Stryker, at UCSF.
And the game is played as follows.
We need to record from the mouse
while the mouse is running around
in what it thinks of as
a naturalistic situation,
looking at these flow patterns
going by on computer screens.
And this is done with a very clever scheme
developed by David Tank,
in which you bolt the mouse's
head to a fixed object,
so you can insert
electrodes to do recordings.
But at the same time,
the mouse is standing
on a ball of styrofoam,
which is elevated by a jet of air.
And the moment of inertia
of the styrofoam ball's
the same as the mouse.
So the mouse is running
around on this ball,
looking at our computer screens.
We can record from his brain
because it's immobilized,
but the mouse thinks he's
running around through the world,
or at least that's our sense
of what we think is going on.
Now, with that setup,
we can evaluate the response
to these flow patterns.
And this becomes a little
bit technical here,
and I'm trying to not be
technical in this talk.
But you can see from this rendition
of what are called the receptive fields
of the visual neurons
in the mouse's brain,
that there's a lot of
structure to the flow
that's at a much higher frequency
than the size of these receptive fields.
And here the red lobe
indicates an excitatory,
and the blue lobe indicates
an inhibitory portion
of the visual field that
the mouse cares about.
And to make a non-technical observation
of the summary of the data,
mice love these scenes.
They love these visual flow stimuli.
They respond at two and a half,
maybe three octaves higher in frequency
to these artificial stimuli.
Contrast matters a lot,
et cetera, et cetera.
And in fact, if you look at
the cells in mouse cortex
that care only about the gradings,
about the classic stimuli,
it's a small percentage.
And so, this is lesson number one.
You need to be very
careful about making sure
that you're exercising the system
at least in a non-trivial way
to the problems that you have.
The second is a data science problem,
which is once we have
this ensemble of stimuli,
the analysis question
becomes much more difficult,
which is, how to analyze the
response of a visual system
to an entire ensemble of stimuli?
Now we have recordings from, let's say,
1,000 neurons to each of the
stimuli in this ensemble,
in this behaving situation.
And so there is a popular
approach to analyzing this.
And this is right at the
heart of what's going on
in the bulk of computational
neuroscience these days,
where you show the mouse the stimulus,
you record from 1,000 neurons,
you measure the response to
neuron one, to stimulus one,
the response of neuron two to
stimulus two, dot, dot, dot.
The response of neuron 1,000 to,
and you do that for each of the stimuli.
It's a high dimensional space.
You reduce dimensionality
with traditional techniques
like PCA and you get what's
called a perceptual manifold.
Now, the key thing about
this perceptual manifold
is each point is a stimulus,
and they're in coordinates
that relate to the activity of mice.
The principle components of the stimulus.
Key thing, each dot in this manifold,
each point on this manifold, is a trial.
So if you imagine yourself
walking around on this,
as you walk on the manifold,
you're walking trial to trial to trial.
What the manifold is telling you about
is in the context of the brain,
how do the trials relate to one another?
Well, this is extremely useful
if your job is to decode
what you think the mouse was looking at.
And for that reason,
these kinds of techniques are
used a lot in brain implants
and other such things,
where you want to decode a
stimulus from the activity.
In understanding the
visual system, however,
we're not out to build a prosthesis.
We're out to figure out
what the circuits are.
These manifolds describe
which trials are similar.
What we wanna know is what
are the neurons doing?
That is to say,
we need something like the
inverse of that manifold.
So instead of representing
trials in neural coordinates,
we need to represent
neurons in coordinates
that relate not only to the trials,
but to the individual responses.
And we've developed an approach
to building this manifold,
and we call it the
neural encoding manifold,
'cause it's in a sense,
the inverse to the
standard decoding manifold.
The key point on this manifold
is neurons live in neighborhoods
where they respond similarly
to the stimulus ensemble
in time to the other neurons around them.
So neurons nearby on this manifold
are likely to be involved
in functional circuits.
Neurons far away are doing
something rather different.
And the hope is that once
we understand this manifold,
it'll tell us something about
abstract functional circuitry,
which can then tell us
something about real circuitry.
So here's the way it looks with real data.
This is the Stryker setup at UCSF,
but because as I described it,
the visual system in the
mouse responds so surprisingly
to these flow stimuli
that we thought we'd better take a look
at the input to the cortex.
And so we teamed up with Greg
Field, who's now at UCLA,
and so we have exactly
analogous presentations
of our stimulus ensemble to the cortex
and to the retina of mice
under comparable conditions.
And that's the siloing
effect that we'll see.
So the stimulus ensemble is
of course all the classic stimuli
because we need to relate to the activity
of the rest of the neuroscience world,
but also a collection of these
flow stimuli that represent
what a mouse would be doing in
a more naturalistic setting.
And they're designed so
that we can titrate out
various aspects of stimulus properties
that we think the mouse
would be interested in.
This is a real version of
that decoding manifold,
the classic approach.
And you can see from this
that the different groups
of stimuli form clouds in that space.
So it would be relatively trivial
from a machine learning perspective
to design decoding algorithms to say
what stimulus the mouse was looking at.
You see the beautiful clustering here
in visual cortex of the mouse.
Well, what does it look
like in the retina?
The clusters are even more
separate. The margins are bigger.
The decoding problem is easier.
So if you want it to solve
this kind of problem,
you're better off using
a retina than a brain.
So what's going on in the brain?
The brain is already doing
something much more complicated,
which seems to make that
classical decoding issue
a rather different one.
So how we will we approach this?
Let me just familiarize you
with the way we present,
I will be presenting the data.
And that is think of a
particular retinal ganglion cell,
and it sees a bunch of stimuli drifting by
in different directions.
Some of these are grading patterns,
some of these are flows of various sorts.
And so for each one of
these, we get a map,
which is the direction of flow
versus the time since
the stimulus came on.
And you can see here that
if this particular neuron
was selective for this
region of visual space,
as the stimulus came by,
it would brrr, quiet,
brrr, quiet, brrr, quiet.
And you could see that as
in one of these directions
of flow, brr, quiet, brrr, quiet, brr.
So red means lots of activity.
Black means not much activity.
You get a similar kind of
picture in the visual cortex,
except now it's a little
bit more structured
in visual cortex,
neurons tend to care about
whether it's drifting this way
with a grading of that orientation,
or drifting this way with a
grading of that orientation.
And so you get the same
kind of distribution
of responses here, but a
bit more refined, okay?
This is two classic examples,
you could find cells
exhibiting this behavior
in the Hubel, Wiesel experiments,
that I talked about at the beginning.
What happens if you show the
entire ensemble of six stimuli?
And that's, I'm going through this.
So you get familiar with thinking
of the different stimulus class
as one of the positions
in this array of activity
for each of the cells.
Well, that cell in V1 that I showed
with the classical Hubel, Wiesel response,
didn't care about any
of the other stimuli.
That's a very classical cell.
Those are the ones on which
deep networks are based.
Most cells don't respond that
way in the visual cortex.
Most cells, for example, this one,
has no interest in low frequency gradings
and has beautiful responses
tuned to orientation
to high frequency gradings,
or to flow patterns that
have orientation structure.
It doesn't like un-oriented,
or just dot kinetic motion patterns at all
unless the contrast is negative, okay?
What's going on here? Here's
another retinal ganglion cell.
This is the one I showed
at the beginning, right?
There's those bursts of activity
as the low frequency grading drifted by.
It loves high frequency gradings.
It loves positive contrast flows.
It doesn't respond at all to
negative contrast flows, right?
What's going on here?
Every neuron is giving a
response in different ways
to this ensemble of stimuli.
This is a pretty complicated
system to begin to understand.
That's why we're trying to
build this encoding manifold
so that we can begin to understand
how these properties are
represented in the visual system.
Now, the heart of the
matter in doing this,
for those of you familiar
with machine learning ideas,
this becomes a very technical
problem in manifold inference.
I'm gonna skip over all those details,
other than to give you a sense
of how the mathematics works behind this.
Which is to say we have
a collection of neurons,
each of which is responding
to an ensemble of stimuli,
and a response is given
as a function in time.
So this is a tensor of data.
And the question is,
"How to say which points
in that tensor of data
are similar to one another?"
Well, points are going to be neurons.
So look at, for example,
neuron I over here.
It likes low frequency gradings
and it likes negative contrast flows,
and it has a strong transient aspect
to its response to the flows
that you don't really see
with the gradings, okay?
Notice that neuron I and
neuron K are really similar
to each other in the
response to the ensemble.
And so we can build
what's called a kernel,
which measures that,
and this is a very
technical aspect of things,
but what it says is neurons I and K
should be close by each
other on this manifold.
Now, neurons I and J,
which are responding quite differently,
notice that I like the
negative contrast flows.
J didn't like those at all.
J liked positive contrast flows.
I didn't respond to those at all.
So I and K are close, J is far away.
You build a graph of these data.
Distances in this graph are
given by this similarity kernel.
In the limit as the number
of neurons gets large,
there's a convergence in
a certain technical sense
of that graph to a manifold,
and that's what we're calling
the neural encoding manifold.
Okay? So near each point is a neuron.
Points nearby are responding
similar to the ensemble.
This is what the data really
looks like for the retina.
As I show it,
while it's projected down
into three dimensions.
But as I show it,
even just projected down
to three dimensions,
you immediately see
that this is a highly
clustered representation
of the neurons.
There are places where
the neurons are very dense
in this representation,
and the places where it's
dense are separated by areas
that are pretty empty of neurons.
And so this highly
clustered representation
for the retina seems to be curious.
Remember, every point in this
representation is a neuron.
So since it's a neuron,
we know it's everything about its response
to our ensemble of stimuli.
Neurons that are in the same
cluster are by definition,
near each other on the manifold,
these high density areas on the manifold.
So they exhibit similar
responses to similar aspects
of the stimulus ensemble.
If I go to a different cluster,
I find a very different
profile of responses
to our ensemble.
If I go to a different
neuron in that cluster,
it looks the same.
So as I walk across this manifold,
I see high density of cells
that are responding similarly, boom.
Then a big jump into cells that
are responding differently.
Boom, a big jump into cells
that are responding differently.
And I can keep doing that.
I can walk over the whole manifold,
and I can keep doing that.
Why would you expect that to be the case?
It turns out that these
clusters are not arbitrary.
They relate to what's
known about the structure
of the retina,
which is retinal ganglion cells
are organized into classes.
In the mouse,
there's thought to be maybe
up to about 40 such classes.
It's thought that in human primates,
there's maybe 20 such classes.
In these 40 classes, they have names,
they have characterization,
they have properties.
The neurons in these clusters
are representing all
those properties, okay?
This is not to say that not much was added
to retinal physiology, but I
would like you to read this
as saying this is a
confirmation in some sense,
that our algorithms are at least
doing something appropriate
with regard to neural activity
because it's learning in a
completely unsupervised fashion
much of the structure of what was known
about retinal ganglion
cell properties, okay?
V1, visual cortex,
the first area that
processes visual information
in human primates,
it's in the occipital lobe way back here
in the back of your brain.
And what do these look like?
The manifold for the
cortex is to the extent
that we can characterize
it completely continuous.
You notice there's this beautiful,
high dimensional structure.
It's hard to tell in this
low dimensional projection.
There's this beautiful
high dimensional structure
with this low dimensional
arm coming out of the side.
There were several years of mathematical
and computational work in front,
trying to develop algorithms
for manifold inference
that work properly in what
are called non-pure manifolds
in mathematics.
Manifolds, where in it,
where the data change their
local intrinsic dimension.
How will we characterize
these continuous manifolds?
Well, each point is a neuron.
So we could stand on a neuron,
we could look at its properties,
and then we could start.
So for example, if we stood
on this neuron over here,
we could look at its properties.
As we start to walk along a
geodesic on this manifold,
we can encounter other neurons
and they have different properties.
And you see, as long as
you go along pathway one,
as cartooned in this diagram,
we go from neurons that
prefer all the stimuli,
highly promiscuous with regard
to our stimulus ensemble,
to neurons that really
only like flow patterns.
And so we go from neurons
over in this corner
that like everything,
to neurons over here that
really only like flows.
What if we went along the opposite
and opposite direction on this manifold?
We see that, again, the properties change,
but as you walk along that direction,
what you lose is selectivity
for low frequency gradings,
responsiveness to low frequency gradings.
Well, we can characterize many aspects
of the structure of the physiology here.
That's not what this talk is about.
But I just want you to
get this kind of picture
of how beautifully
continuous this structure is,
and how we can characterize
various aspects of it.
Remember in the beginning,
I talked about the
importance of the stimuli.
The difficulty of working only
with the classical low frequency gradings
is these are the neurons that
care about those primarily.
It's only this low frequency arm.
So a lot of visual
physiology is based on one,
actually quite special
branch of the manifold
of neurons in visual cortex.
These neurons over here on this
side that liked everything,
they're primarily inhibitory
interneurons because it,
and in fact,
it's known that there are many properties
of inhibitory interneurons
that lead them to respond widely
to different classes of stimuli.
We can take this on and on,
and we can characterize many
physiological properties
about the distribution
and densities of neurons
at different layers, how
they're related to each other.
That's all visual neuroscience.
Why would you expect this
topological diversity
that we found in these
two manifolds to arise?
This is a real segregation in the nature
of the computations going on.
Well, one of the areas we
work on in my building a lot
is spectral graph theory.
So here's spectral graph
theory in three seconds, okay?
If you have a collection of neurons
that are tightly coupled to each other
in a functional network,
then the manifold
corresponding to that graph
will be a dense,
continuous little cluster.
If you have several of these circuits
and they're distinct from one another,
then you'll have a discontinuous manifold
represented in the stimulus
response, extrinsic coordinates.
If you start to add some
weak coupling between these,
then some of these
islands start to connect
up to each other a little bit.
So you have a big island structure
with some weak interconnections
in between them.
And we think that's what's
going on in the retina.
The weak interconnections in the retina
are what are called amacrine
cells or gap junctions
between retinal ganglion cells, et cetera.
We know a lot about the
physiology and anatomy
that could underlie that.
In cortex, the game is
completely different.
Zillions of neurons are connected
to zillions of other neurons,
and the situation is much
higher dimensional, much richer,
much more densely interconnected.
So all this makes a lot of sense.
That's the intro. That's the
science that we care about.
Here's the part that may
be relevant for you, right?
I said at the beginning, we
have these deep, deep networks.
We started to work with visual networks,
but we're, yeah, there's
a lot more to be said.
So we can now ask this
question, not at the level of,
"Does a unit in a deep network
resemble a unit in the retina
or a unit in the brain?
But does the topology
of the encoding manifold
in the artificial network represent
one of these structures?"
Okay? I won't embarrass
anybody by asking. Okay?
So here's what you do.
The first question you're
worried about, I know, is, well,
"Is AI an appropriate object
for us to be working with?"
'Cause the fact that we can
technically interrogate it
exactly the same way that we
interrogate the biological data
isn't so much the point.
Is it appropriate? So what
are these deep networks?
This is ResNet-50, a classic
computer vision network.
It's trained on this famous library
of natural scenes called ImageNet.
There are millions of them.
And it has this spectacular
ability to classify
in instances of these scenes
into, for example, spiderwebs,
or one of 1,000 or so other categories.
This has been all over
the cover of Nature.
It's been all over the
cover of the New York Times.
You all know this story, okay?
So we get feeded our
stimuli. They're just images.
We feed it our stimuli.
And if, for example,
we look at the activity across the layers
of one of these networks,
we see that for ImageNet-like
patterns or our patterns,
we get similar kinds of
activity distributions, okay?
What's the output?
These networks happily classify
our stimuli as, for example,
positive contrast flows are spiderwebs
and ResNet does that
with 93.5% confidence.
So we think that's with regard to,
I don't know if that's a
prediction or a causation,
but that's a pretty confident prediction,
that's a pretty confident
estimation of one sort or another.
What does the manifold look like?
It's even more clustered than the retina.
Remember the way I showed individual,
so in this case, we call them
units rather than neurons,
because they're the equivalent
in these deep networks.
If you were to look at the
responses plotted the same way,
for one of these units, you'd say,
"Ah, that's pretty similar
to the kinds of units,
some of the kinds of units
that we saw in the visual system."
Do they tile space the way
that retinal ganglion cells do?
Yes, they do.
There's a beautiful tiling
of space in the same way
that retinal ganglion cells tile space.
But in retrospect, that
shouldn't be a surprise,
because all these tricks that are used
to make these networks
trainable, like weight sharing,
are in fact imposing that as a condition.
So even though individually,
these things kind of look like neurons,
globally, they look and
enjoy the properties
of something more like a
retina than like a brain.
These are big retinas. These
are not little brains, hmm?
You can go across different layers,
different networks, et cetera.
Same thing holds.
So what I tried to illustrate
by taking this deep dive
into the visual system
is building up an infrastructure
for understanding populations
of neurons' responses
in respect to an ensemble
of stimuli across time.
The full set of data that
you need to worry about
leads to very different ways
of thinking about things
and opened a direction into
comparing deep networks
with retinas, with V1,
very specific retinal ganglion cell types
look very much like certain of the units
in these deep networks.
V1 is distributed very, very differently.
V1 is this continuous manifold,
and we think that it's
that continuous manifold
that forms the substrate out
of which the emergent phenomena
that Priya,
I think would call cognitive
activity can emerge.
That's not the case in the retina.
From these algorithms,
you can compute dimensionality
and you see the lowest dimensional objects
are the ones from the artificial networks.
The intermediate dimension
stuff is the retina,
which has some of this amacrine cell
mediated behavior introduced.
But cortex, even the first visual area
of cortex is drastically different.
This was a big team effort.
We did the computational work here.
Mike's group at UCSF
did the cortical work.
Greg Field was at Duke, now is at UCLA,
did the retina stuff.
And I'd like to just underline the fact
that this was a spectacular collaboration
between experimentalists
of different breeds
and theoreticians of different breeds.
And we think that's really
the future of all of this.
Thank you.
- Thank you so much, Steve.
(audience applauding)
Thanks for cracking open one case
where you have managed to decode
what resonant actually does with spatial,
broken up how the inference
actually happens within ResNet
by mapping it onto actually retinal cells,
real physical entities.
So cracking open that proverbial black box
that we've all talked about.
So a question to Joe, and then start.
- [Joe] Thanks,
so one of the things I
really liked about this,
this setup, is the way that you've got,
not just the changing visual flow,
but also more or less correlated
with the movement of the mouse,
even though the mouse is stable
because of the ball arrangement, right?
But I'm curious whether there's any,
what the arrangement is for
figuring in the mouse's head
and eye movements, things
which are not constrained,
I take it,
- Right.
- Which are clearly part
of the actual tracking
of changing visual,
your movement in relation
to the movement around
is really important in vision.
So how does that play
into this kind of project?
- Oh, it's a great question.
We worried about that a lot.
And the head is fixed.
- [Joe] Ah.
- But the eyes can move.
So Mike recorded eye movements.
And then Greg,
who did an exogenous recording
with pieces of retina,
moved the stimulus around
as if it were being
seen through those eye movements.
- [Joe] Ah. So that correlated
to the eye movements?
That's really cool.
- And in fact, we used
the actual eye movement.
- [Joe] Oh yeah, that would
be the point. Yeah. Yeah.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thanks for all the great talk.
So could you repeat, I missed it.
How did you pick three as
the embedding dimension
of the lower dimensional manifold?
And also,
- How did we pick three?
Oh, oh, oh, because three
makes for a nice video.
I don't really know how to
display four dimensions at once.
- [Audience Member] And
also, did you, like...
- We know a lot about
the intrinsic dimension
of these manifolds.
- [Audience Member] Cool.
And also, do you happen to look into,
since you were looking at
topology of that manifold,
did you look for non-trivial homology?
Do any topological analysis?
Are there non-trivial cycles?
Like in those things
that are branching out?
- Yeah, no, thus far, yeah.
So thus far,
we've been able to characterize
only certain aspects
of the topology because
we're restricted to,
we have about 1,500
neurons from the retina,
about 1,500 from the cortex.
And if we start to look for
things like persistent topology
and that other stuff,
that induces an artificial
clustering on all of this
by the way that neighborhoods are grown.
So we actually experimented
some of those techniques,
but have not been using them.
- [Audience Member 1] Thanks
so much for your talk.
I had a question about
the kind of implications
or consequences of your results.
So are you thinking of this
as something about the architecture
of the neural network as deciding this?
Or is it something about the problem
that's allowing the
architecture to take on
this kind of retinal
neuron versus brain neural?
- Right. Yeah, well,
they're coupled, right?
The retina has a very
particular cyto architecture.
The cortex of the mouse
has a very particular cyto architecture.
There are certain macroscopic details
of the cyto architectural
organization of the mouse
that do not have certain
properties of advanced primates,
advanced mammals actually,
like primates or cats,
which are called orientation columns
and other such activities.
So one of the technical
motivations for this work
from the physiology side,
is in order to do the geometric processing
that has thought that orientation
hyper columns support,
you need the hyper column organization.
And because that's lacking in the mouse
except at a crude statistical level.
And what this implies is no,
you do not need that organization,
at least at the level of
the first visual area.
Of course, there's much
higher level stuff going on
beyond what I talked about
here, but maybe next year.
- [Priya] Any other quick questions?
Okay, let's thank Steve again.
(audience applauding)